just try and withhold judgment and [ __ ]
whoever leaked it hey everybody it's
Charlie so you've all seen the trailer
you know that Barry's gonna wear the old
season 1 costume in the first episode
but Cisco and team flash are gonna make
another new costume that he's going to
wear that's gonna be more comic-book
accurate so I'll explain what's going on
I'll address grant gustin's comments too
because that kind of validates what's
going on if you're brand new to the
channel there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway - all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video flash is dropping
f-bombs so a couple days ago somebody
sent me this picture and I actually just
thought that it was just really awesome
fan cosplay like this person wearing it
is not grant gustin but now it seems
like based on grant gustin's reaction on
his Instagram story this is legit and
this is what it will look like before
they tune it up with special effects so
during the comic-con panel they revealed
that yeah they would have the flash ring
because we saw it in the trailer it's
gonna be really awesome
it's the season 1 costume noir makes
that funny joke fan favorite costume
they're talking about season 1 there's
gonna be a lot of season 1 jokes during
the first episode but the producer said
that later they're going to get another
new more comic book accurate costume so
when people saw this they're like wait
you know what's going on with this
costume because you only see it from the
chest up so when they say it's going to
be more comic-book accurate they
designed it so that they can tune it in
special effects a little bit better and
so that practically it's easier for
Grant Gustin to wear like it actually
takes a while for them to climb in and
out of these costumes so when they say
it's more comic-book accurate what
they're talking about is the new 52 suit
the one exception to that though is the
chin right here there's no actual chin
strap as you would call it the cowboy
usually covers this part Grant Gustin
did say that they had already changed
the suit just a little bit since they
did this so this is actually just a
prototype for what the real version will
look like when you see him run you see
the speedforce lines
trace around parts of his chest that's
why this suit is designed to be a little
bit more angular because it's easier for
the people that actually
add those special effects to add them to
surfaces like this I'll explain how that
works but here's a quick montage of the
old versions of the suit starting with
season 1 then when he gets the new
emblem then the sad berry suit from once
in future flash then the season 4
costume which is close to being a
version of that future berry costume
from season 3 something I've been
playing with designed to replace the
turnouts firefighters traditionally wear
I thought if STAR Labs could do
something nice for the community maybe
people wouldn't be so angry dr. wells
anymore how is it going to help me I
added a little upgrade to your suit it's
just like the one from the future
newspaper Gideon showed us I was
thinking you know you shouldn't fear the
future anymore right
no and I'll be here faster than we think
I thought it was about time I did
something underneath all this red
beautiful life built in self repairing
armor nano liquid circuitry full
spectrum scanning and a whole bunch of
other big words chief among them
your very own custom-made hood the way
they explained that season one costume
and the reason why it looks so different
from the comics is because it was
supposed to be a firefighters prototype
costume that they found lying around the
producers wanted to treat it like a
Batman Year Zero situation whereby like
you know Batman doesn't start out with
the most awesome version of his Batman
costume right away so Barry slowly
upgrades his costume here to here as we
get to that season 10 crisis on Infinite
Earths moment so if you were wondering
if they were gonna make even more new
costumes in future seasons I think the
answer is absolutely yes like they just
fine-tune things and practically the
suit gets easier for Grant Gustin to
walk around in and there are actually a
couple different versions of this that
he wears on set there's this version
that you see in the picture where the
cowl is fixed on his face so that he can
turn his head and it'll stay on then
there's another version of the suit with
a really soft cowl for when he pulls the
mask off and it just hangs behind his
head like a hoodie that's a completely
different version of the suit than this
one right here then there's the one that
they always put on the dummy they
actually made jokes about that last
season there's always a flash suit on
the dummy but when he takes the suit to
put it on and go save somebody the dummy
disappears so they always make jokes on
set behind the scenes like where does
the dummy go so after they filmed the
season 4 finale last year like they all
had this funny moment where they're like
okay we're done
Grant Gustin and Carlo Valdez picked up
the dummy and just carried it out like
well we're not gonna need to use the
flash costume for a couple more months
till we come back to film season 5
so one kind of upset that that didn't
make the DVD bonus features but the
biggest thing that's going on here is
that you're gonna see more special
effects when Barry's running they just
make it look a little bit cooler every
single year because special effects get
better and because Barry is supposed to
get more powerful as he runs he gets
more full of speed for so that's why you
know retro actively they're not gonna
break any of their continuity so like
season 1 Barry not quite as powerful not
quite as full of Speed Force so you
don't see that
matter electricity careening all over
his body when he runs but from a
special-effects standpoint they have
changed the way that they do some of
those things so like zoom during season
two is a good example like you see that
lightning careening all over his body
when he steals Barry's speed force or
when he's just standing still
the biggest reasons why they don't do
that for Barry is is because he had not
become as full of Speed Force yet at
that point but also because it's really
expensive from a special-effects
standpoint as silly as that sounds they
said that when they were plotting out
their zoom arc in all the episodes that
he would appear in they would have to
budget for the special effects when he
would come on screen because there
aren't that many times when you just see
him standing around without blue
electricity all over his body they just
wanted to make him see more and more
powerful that's why they changed it when
saboteur became a thing because then
they could do scenes where he was just
standing still and they would just make
the suit look a little bit shinier and
that was about it
but aside from some glowy light effects
you don't see a whole lot of extra
special effects until they actually
start fighting each other and it goes
into full CG
like I told you from the beginning
and the future this is sort of the weird
part of them making these television
shows like they would make it look like
this in the comics all the time if they
could but it's actually surprisingly
expensive to do stuff like this even
when they're just standing still so
again just a couple reasons why the
costume looks like this like it's made
to be more lightweight so that it's more
comfortable to wear
but also so that it's easier for them to
do comic-book special effects when he's
running and using the Speed Force
because they just introduced that flash
ring that's probably gonna be what he
uses for his costume for at least the
next couple of years there's one big
Power Move from the comics that he
hasn't done yet they haven't figured
this out on the TV show and probably
just because it's really expensive from
a budget standpoint and that's creating
the costume using speed force constructs
so let me know in the comments what do
you think about them doing a more new 52
looking version of the flash costume
what I'm hoping is is that now that
everybody knows what this looks like CW
will reveal an official poster for what
it looks like when it's all shiny with
special effects so maybe we'll get that
in the next couple of weeks but I was
not expecting this to drop so I'm
working on Captain Marvel Avengers for
stuff that should post in a little while
but click here for my big breakdown of
the flash panel from the other day where
they talk about the hundredth episode
and the crossover click here to rewatch
that season 5 trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]